Alright let's do this one last time.
You're a bit late. We can't all be everywhere at once. Well a text might have been nice.
I was gone for less than 2 hours. What happened? Okay, okay, okay.
I know what it looks like. But...Here's the good news. Ah, here we go. The Multiverse didn't collapse.
Oh cool! Ah, little touch and go. But it worked out. Great story. Hey, do you finish the goober?
It's not a goober, it's a gizmo. Do you always have to call me out. It's just really frustrating and bums me out.
Don't get too excited Miguel, it's just a prototype. Not excited.
But you could be the first person to make an autonomous multiverse jump.
Or the last. Okay, so we're just gonna roll the dice on this?
So what do you say pal? Where you wanna go first?
Let's start at the beginning one last time earth 67.
Welcome back, everyone it's Charlie!
This is going to be my new Spider-Man into
the spider verse 2 video the producers of
the first movie also revealed a whole bunch
of alternate endings and deleted scenes from
the end of the first spider verse movie.
So we'll break it all down doing in Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is be
subscriber and leave your favorite moment
from spider verse on the video what a great
time to go back and rewatch the movie now
because were still under quarantine and talking
about animation one of the great things about
animation is that most people who are working
on animated movies and TV shows are still
able to work right now, whereas a lot of live-action
stuff like all the Marvel movies have been
delayed welders all talk about the alternate
ending and deleted scenes from the first spider
verse movie then all talk about Spider-Man
into the spider verse 2.
So for Lori Chris Miller the writers and producers
the first Spider-Man into the spider verse
movie recently revealed how they completely
change the third act of the movie after they'd
already released the first full teaser trailer
for it.
What happened is the because they were within
a year of the movie coming out is that they
already animated most of the scenes at the
end of the film.
This is big supercollider battle, but they
needed to change it to make the film work.
They just felt like the version that they
originally had wasn't as good as what we wound
up with in the final version, but because
so much of it had been finished already they
had to find a way to change the order of the
sequences so that it told a different story
and they could add different dialogue to the
moments.
There were also a couple scenes they just
deleted wholesale that they put on the Blu-ray
that all include in this to, so if you look
at these whiteboards the red marker are all
the changes that they made to the final version
of the movie soul explain what those are.
But then after they revealed all this, the
editor of the film came out separately and
said oh in July just six months before the
movie came out.
I also made a bunch of my own changes to the
end of the film.
So just to be clear, this is all from the
giant supercollider tack at the end of the
movie were team Spider-Man goes to stop kingpin
and then all return home they referred to
the team in the notes here as the spiders
so the spiders show up to stop kingpin, but
it all starts with kingpin in this moment.
Here is their note say is going great for
KP kingpin abbreviation excavation point is
families arriving but wait, Peter B. Parker
arrives and says sorry kingpin the parties
over.
This makes Vanessa go away then kingpin yells
more as Dr. octopus attacks Peter then you
start to seal the red marker changes that
they made to the plot miles arrives to save
the day must prove himself to Peter in order
to save him save Peter B Parker note that
they just said saves her from a weird thing
then removed his mask showing himself to her,
because they hadn't seen him in his new costume
yet.
If it wasn't clear the black costume that
Miles wears is actually the original blonde
ultimate Peter Parker's main costume the classic
Spider-Man costume that was read that he was
looking at earlier made gave him Peter's old
main costume I thought that you would need
this the story of the movie is all about him
becoming Spider-Man them passing the torch
to him because that version of Peter died
at the beginning of the film so want make
giving him Peter's old costume is a way of
saying no, you're Spider-Man now you're the
Spider-Man of this earth.
Then in their whiteboard notes here says the
team gains the upper hand they be Dr. octopus,
everyone gets a moment to celebrate get all
the fist bumps then is Miles triple Lindy
go if you see a lot of classic Rodney Dangerfield.
You might remember this reference the triple
Lindy is actually a Rodney Dangerfield diving
joke from the movie back to school which also
started a very young Robert Downey Junior
Iron Man himself.
There's the bike when line Miles has Peter
go now, Peter says you're not ready yet.
I didn't want to leave you there's things
I can teach you.
Miles proves he is ready.
He says go Peter says no you're my one person
my one person is trying to save Miles says
no I'm not, then says call your wife talking
about Peter B. Parker's Mary Jane who he been
crying about through the entire film then
in their notes.
It says Miles faces KP alone kingpin shoulder
touched the hay movies apps and with his venom
attack which he can now do on command.
So some of the major changes that they made
to the end of this film is the way that they
originally focused way more on the Miles Gwen
relationship.
There were more romantic overtones in their
original versions, but they made the ending
here more about what's going on between Miles
and Peter B. Parker, because that relationship
is much more important to the themes of the
film and about him taking the mantle of Spider-Man
because Peter B. Parker is sort of a representation
or a call back to the original Peter Parker
at the beginning of the film.
One of the other big changes as they focus
way more on the different spiders getting
there big callback moments to earlier in the
movie like Spider-Man noir with his Rubiks
cube having just discovered color I'm taking
this with me as if he slowly finding happiness
in finding color then there's all the changes
that the editor of the film made it just six
months before the movie came out.
Keep in mind too that a lot of these changes
are happening after they'd released a couple
really big trailers for the movie one of his
big changes was Spider-Man war fighting tombstone
with his hat instead of his guns Spider-Man
noir just one of the very, very few versions
of Spider-Man who actually uses guns as his
main weapons instead of just using his biological
weapons like as web shooters or any other
biological weapons that Spider-Man versions
can generate he change the goodbye line for
spider pig that'll do pig which is a Simpsons
spider pig callback from The Simpsons movie,
which itself is also a reference to the bay
movie about the pig.
If you look a lot of the numbers on these
whiteboards here those of the numbers of the
sequences in the order that they happen and
a lot of these change, especially when they
were fighting the order that they fight the
villains in just to provide more solid callbacks
to earlier in the film like when Miles is
fighting here you see him mimicking all the
moves that he saw the original Peter Parker
using in his collider fight at the beginning
of the film they change the kingpin fight
a lot to make it resonate more with Miles
and his father Jefferson who was watching
this all go down in the final version in the
original version kingpin loses Vanessa at
the beginning when Peter B. Parker shows up
and says the parties over in the final version.
They show his wife and son from the alternate
universe witnessing his fight was Spider-Man
just like the original versions of his wife
and son witnessed it turning away from him
just like they did in drives kingpin over
the edge in then kingpin threatens Miles family
while Jefferson is watching this go down.
Then there was another big deleted scene from
their fight here.
They put on the Blu-ray as their note say
kingpin goes after his father Miles saves
him, and then when Jefferson looks up he's
gone as the note say like Batman quote of
quote in the final version.
They just end it with that simple phone call
between the 2 of them a call back to earlier
in the film, you know Miles you can talk to
me about anything is a little more heartfelt
but let me know in the comments.
What you think about some of these changes
in deleted scenes.
Spider verse wound up being one of the best
Spider-Man movies of all time.
Not just animated movies but any kind of Spider-Man
movie overall.
It took them about four years to make Spider-Man
into the spider verse which gives you an idea
for why it's taking so long for them to make
the Sequel Spider-Man into the spider verse 2,
but talk about what's going on with that the
teaser trailer all the Easter eggs and reveals
we arty have for that movie right now the
movies coming out April 2022.
So around this time.
2 years into the future.
The probably release the very first full trailer
about a year before the movie comes out so
about a year from now if you're a big avatar
the last Airbender fan.
The director of Spider-Man into the spider
verse 2 is Joaquin Dos Santos who came up
on that first avatar series.
He's also worked on a bunch of other animated
series recently to their over 20 different
versions of Spider-Man that they tease with
those logos in the teaser trailer they released
earlier this year the stilly before five main
characters, but most of the characters from
the first film will return for the second
one, but there's the red spray paint Miles
logo the shiny neon one is for Spider-Man
2099 which is obviously part of that post
credit scene.
He's the one the engineer the Parker industries
web where watches that now allow them to freely
travel around the multi-verse, which sort
of explains the mechanics of the second film
the supercollider was the reason for the cross
over in the first film, but obviously that
I can accrete another supercollider for the
second film in the Spider-Man to the spider
verse comics in the spider get in comics.
They have web where watches which allow them
to open small portals the other moment with
Miles and Gwen at the end where she opens
the small portal to say hello to him also
implies that that's a little while after that
in Spider-Man 2099 has already given her one
of those watches so that she can open portals
to Miles earth the Spider-Man I'm probably
most excited for the second one, though, is
the soup I demand the Japanese Spider-Man
from the 1970s to a TV show is the yellow
and red logo here in because they confirm
that he's going to be in the Sequel.
I'm also assuming there can include his neck
with them to because it's her to come hand-in-hand
together, Ben Reilly shows up here during the
teaser.
So I'm interested to see if they tried to
do some sort of clone saga through the spider
verse films.
The animated spider verse films also try to
cross over with a live-action films a little
bit they wanted to include some live-action
sequences with Tom Holland Spider-Man tying
it to MCU in the venom verse movies venom
himself doesn't appear during any of the logos
here, but I'm also curious to see how they
deal with the symbiosis in the venom character,
because he's such a big Spider-Man comic book
character you would figure they would put
venom in the sequel somewhere the other really
cool teaser here is the ghost spider logo.
I'm curious to see what they do with him and
animation.
He's been using the Spider-Man PS4 game is
one of the skins, but you don't see a lot
of him in the cartoons or obvious he hasn't
shown up in the live-action series yet either.
Then there's the captain universe Spider-Man.
This is a crazy OP version of Spider-Man.
I'm just curious to see what they do with
them.
So just let me know in the comments which
new Spider-Man are you most excited about
based on this teaser trailer and because of
all the quarantine this been going on, let
me know in the comments if you guys want me
to do some kind of rewatch project with the
Marvel movies the venom to trailer is supposed
to be arriving sometime soon.
If they do wind up posting that of course
I'll do a video is long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel.
You should see that video when I posted everyone
click here for my new Spider-Man venom to
video and click here for my breakdown of that
other Spider-Man into the spider verse 2
teaser trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe see you guys tonight!